et puis c'est évidemment très important
de faire ce déplacement en compagnie
d'un grand président de région laurent
bocquet qui a littéralement transformé
sa région et qui a fait justement de
l'égalité des territoires de l'égalé
dignité des territoires j'allais dire le
philo de son action avec le succès
conseil écoutez je sais que ça vous
dérange que la droite soit de retour je
sais que ça vous dérange peut-être aussi
qu'elle soit totalement unie mais on va
gagner ensemble et bercy - guy
d'abord suis très heureux d'accueillir
valérie pécresse ici et pour moi c'était
important de l'accueillir chez moi en
haute-loire dans notre région tout le
monde sait l'attachement que j'ai à ce
territoire et accueillir valérie ici un
symbole c'est un symbole qui répondra
très simplement à votre question c'est
le symbole de mon soutien et de mon
engagement total aux côtés de valen
valérie a fait un début de campagne qui
était très important qui consistait à
tourner les pages du passé
toutes ces questions pardon de vous le
dire mais qui sont absolument pas à la
hauteur du sujet que vous posez l'enjeu
pour nous c'est la présidentielle il
angers pour nous c'est de savoir ce
qu'on veut proposer aux français pour
reconstruire aux côtés de valérie et je
serai totalement engagé à ses côtés dans
cette campagne parce que c'est la seule
chose qui m'intéresse